[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: All
right, it's 11:05.
Let's get started.
So the agenda for today,
we're doing this whole thing
on the methods in human
cognitive neuroscience.
And I'm illustrating
those methods
with the case of
face perception.
Not just because I'm
into face perception,
but it's a particularly
rich domain of research
where there's lots to
say about it from all
these different methods.
And so last time,
we talked a bit
about applying Marr's
computational theory
level to face perception.
We talked a teeny bit
about some behavioral data
and a little bit
about functional MRI.
What I'm going to
do today is quickly
zoom through a speeded-up
review of those things,
and then we're going to get to
some of these other methods.
And there's a quiz at the end.
All right?
OK, so methods in
any field of science
are just there to enable us to
answer scientific questions.
They're not to
impress our friends
with all the fancy
things we know how to do
or our colleagues.
They're just to
answer questions.
And so you always have to
start with the questions.
And so last time, I listed
a bunch of questions.
Not all of them, but
a bunch of questions
one would really want to
know about face perception
if we were to understand
how it works in the brain.
And last time, we focused
on these first three.
So let me just do a
super quick review.
The questions at the level of
Marr's computational theory,
we ask, what is the
problem that's being solved
and why is that important
to the organism?
What is the input,
what is the output?
How much you get from that
input to that output, right?
So for the case of
face perception,
here's a very simple
version of it.
Here's an example of the input.
It goes in, hits the retina.
The stuff that we want to
understand happens in here,
and you have an output.
OK, so just even thinking
about it that way,
we can already just
see, with common sense,
that one of the big challenges
in solving this problem
is that faces look different
every time you see them.
The lighting changes,
the orientation
of the face changes, the hair
changes, the mood changes,
all this stuff happens.
People put on makeup, they
shave off their facial hair,
they do all these things
to make it a big challenge
to recognize faces.
And yet, we manage really well.
So how do we do that?
Well, our field has many methods
to address this question.
Last time, I talked
about one little example
of a behavioral study--
simple, cognitive psychology
study measuring behavior--
where we showed that the way
people solve this
problem is fundamentally
different with
people they know well
and people they don't know well.
So I showed an example
that all of you
presumably would have
no trouble determining
that those are all pictures
of the same person,
even though at the pixel level
they're wildly different.
And yet, you have a hell of
a time saying which of those
images are of the same
people and which aren't.
And so the point
is that our ability
to extract this invariant
representation, that
is to figure out
abstractly who is that,
is really-- well, to figure
out that any of these images
are the same as each other
is much better for familiar
than unfamiliar faces.
And that means we don't have
a perfectly general ability
to take any face and
abstract out this completely
image-independent version of it.
That's what invariant
representation is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For the case
of the Dutch politicians,
did they ever do
the study on people
who were super recognizers?
NANCY KANWISHER: I
don't know about that,
but they did do it
on people who are
professional TSA-type people.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NANCY KANWISHER: Right?
And I'll tell you
guys about that later.
But you could think
about whether you
think it might work better
with those people or not.
OK, everybody get this
general point here?
All right.
So I skipped over another
simple behavioral finding
last time that I
want to mention now.
And that is an
extremely low tech--
charmingly low tech, and yet, I
think very powerful-- discovery
about face perception.
One of the most
important original bits
of evidence that
face perception might
be a different thing in the
brain came from a PhD thesis
in this department by
a guy named Robert Yin.
And he used the extremely
high tech equipment
of a stopwatch and paper.
OK, so what did he do?
He presented faces
to people upright.
And he said, study
these 20 faces.
And then he tested them later.
Did you see this face?
And then he did the
exact same experiment
on a different set of faces,
but they were all upside down.
Studied upside down
and tested upside down.
And what did he find?
He found what's known as
the face inversion effect.
Namely, people do much
worse at this task
when the faces are upside down.
Here's errors for
inverted upside down,
errors for upright at this task.
Even though, importantly,
they were studied and tested
upside down or studied
and tested inverted--
upright.
OK, everybody got
what this shows?
OK, so that's cool that
this face inversion--
but the further cool thing is he
showed that this face inversion
effect is greater for faces
than for other kinds of stimuli.
So he tested lots
of other things,
including houses
and stick figures.
And he showed that
that cost, when
you turn the
stimuli upside down,
is greater, that
difference is greater
for faces than for other
classes of stimuli.
So what that suggests is that
face recognition may just
work differently in some
deep way from recognition
of other classes of stimuli.
And Robert Yin actually
inferred in his PhD thesis--
way, way back before
any imaging method--
that maybe there
are special parts
of the brain for
face recognition.
And maybe face recognition is
just a totally different thing,
that's why it is more
affected by inversion
than recognition of
other kinds of things.
Was there a question back there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
ask, could that just be
because faces are much more
complex than houses or stick
figures and that--
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
Hang on to--
AUDIENCE: --backwards.
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
That's a very good question.
And many people have tried
to grapple with that.
And actually,
about 10 years ago,
the idea that this
disproportionate effect
for faces was standard
textbook, completely accepted.
And now there's another
round of people doubting it
with other kinds of stimuli.
So it's kind of ongoing.
It's a very robust difference,
but to say exactly what it
is about face stimuli versus
other kinds of things that
is responsible for
that difference,
you can imagine it's subtle.
For the purposes
of this course, I'm
trying to not quite
lie to you guys,
but give you the most standard
view without freighting you
with every possible objection
to every little thing.
Because pretty
much every finding,
there's somebody who
has a beef with it.
We'll tell you,
that's not really
true because blah-di-blah.
OK?
So yes, there's a little
bit of debate going on
about this right now.
But for the purposes
of this course,
it's pretty damn rock solid, at
least as an empirical result.
All right.
So there's in fact lots of
versions of the face inversion
effect.
One you may have seen before
but which is very amusing.
If you look at faces like
this that are upside down,
they look sort of normal.
But then if you rotate
them, you realize
there's something
deeply weird going on.
So the point is,
you're much more
sensitive to those
grotesquely distorted faces
when you see them right side
up than when you see them
upside down.
So that's another version of
the face inversion effect,
and there are many, many
incarnations of this effect.
You'll see another one
later in the lecture.
So where did we get last
time with these questions?
We got that one of the major, if
not the major central challenge
in face recognition at
a computational level,
is the fact that we deal
with huge image variation
each time we see a face.
And yet, somehow we're
able to grapple with it.
So to understand how face
recognition works will
be to understand,
what is the code,
ultimately-- nobody
knows right now--
but what is a code
running in our heads that
enables us to do that?
What is our mental
representation
of a face that enables us
to deal with this problem?
By looking at behavioral
data, we got some evidence
from the Dutch politician
study that whatever
that representation is
that we extract from faces,
it's not independent of
the particular image.
It's not that we have some
platonic ideal of the face
that we can extract
from any face
that lands on our retina,
platonic ideal of that person's
face, right?
So whatever we're doing, it's
not completely invariant,
because we can't do that so
well with unfamiliar faces.
Also, as I just
showed you-- related,
but not exactly the same point--
our mental
representations of faces
are very sensitive to the
orientation of the face
more than our mental
representations
of other classes of stimuli.
So those are just very simple
insights about whatever
our representations of
faces are in our heads,
just from simple
behavioral data.
OK, so let me just review some
of the strengths and weaknesses
of simple behavioral methods.
Strengths are, they're
good for characterizing
the internal
representation, right?
Not with huge
computational precision,
they're more like with
gisty kind of ideas.
They're not very
invariant, they depend
on the orientation, right?
That's not very precise,
but it's a whole lot better
than nothing.
That's what I mean by
at least qualitatively.
They're good for disassociating
mental phenomena.
So you've already seen that
when the inversion effect,
it happens more for
faces than other things.
So that already starts
to tell us, OK, maybe
whatever the code in
our head is that we
use for face
recognition, maybe it's
pretty different than the
code that we use in our head
to recognize objects.
OK, it's also cheap.
It's really cheap.
Much cheaper than all
the other methods.
OK, weaknesses--
behavioral methods
alone don't have any
relationship to the brain,
at least without
doing extra work.
And it's not that they're
useless until you link them
to the, brain it's
just that the brain is
a whole source of other data.
And it's nice to link
them, because then you
can connect with all
those other data.
Also, behavioral data
are pretty sparse.
For the most part, you have
accuracy and reaction time,
and that's it.
And that's just not a whole
lot of data to work with.
You have to actually
be much smarter
to be a behavioral
cognitive psychologist,
than you have to be a
cognitive neuroscientist,
where you have much richer
data to reason from.
Cognitive psychologists really
have very, very clever designs
because they're taking
this extremely limited data
and trying to pull out
interesting insights
about mental function.
Another way of
looking at that is,
here's an eyeball and a bunch
of processing going over stages
and a response, right?
With behavioral data, all
you have is that response.
But presumably, for most of
the mental processes that
go on in our heads, there
are many different stages
of processing where different
things are going on.
Computations tend to
have multiple stages
and unfold over time.
And all we have is the output.
So really, what we
want to be able to do
is characterize the whole
sequence of processes.
And it's not that you
can't get insights
about some of
those intermediates
from behavioral data, it's
just much more challenging.
So if we had a way to look at
those things independently,
wouldn't that be awesome?
OK, so there's lots
of ways to do that.
And a particularly good
one is functional MRI.
So as I mentioned before--
I mentioned this very briefly--
this very early experiment
that I did way back asking
whether there is a region of
the brain that's selectively
involved in processing faces.
And I'm going to put a
slightly different spin on it
from what I put before.
It's the same
experiment, same data,
but I want to emphasize
more the logic
of the experimental design
because you guys will
be designing an experiment on
a different topic due Monday
night.
That we're going to discuss
Sunday night-- that we're going
to discuss in class on Monday.
So we start with a
hypothesis that there's
a region of the brain
that's selectively
responsive to faces.
That's the hypothesis.
The way we test it is to
pop people in a scanner
and show them faces and objects.
The data that I
showed you before
is that this little
patch of the brain--
remember, this is a horizontal
slice, back of the head,
left and right are flipped.
So that little region in
me is right about in there.
Everybody oriented?
OK.
That region responds much
more to faces than objects.
Is that clear to
everybody what that is?
OK.
So yes, you see that
in most subjects.
So yes, there's a bit that
responds more to faces
than objects.
But now, let's
consider the hypothesis
that that region is really
selective to faces per se.
And the way you evaluate
whether these data,
how strongly these data
support that hypothesis--
they're certainly
consistent with it,
but do they nail that
hypothesis fully--
is to consider, are there
any other alternative
accounts we can think of that
are consistent with these data
and different from
that hypothesis?
Is that clear?
It's really important.
That's just the whole kernel
of scientific thinking
and evaluating evidence is
asking yourself that question.
Is there any other way we
could get those data where
that hypothesis wasn't true?
And if so, you've got
to grapple with it.
So what you do next is you
think up alternative hypotheses
to the one you
started with, that
is different accounts
of the same data.
And so in our case, you guys
suggested a whole bunch,
I suggested a bunch.
And then the next
thing I showed you
is that we can test those
alternative hypotheses,
at least these ones
here, by first--
what we did was, I didn't
really emphasize this
before-- but we
reran that experiment
in a new bunch of subjects,
each subject individually.
We found in each subject the
little bit that does this.
We write down exactly where
that is in that person's brain.
Now that we found that region--
that's called a localizer
run, because we're finding
that region in each subject
individually-- now we
can ask it new questions.
And so the new questions
we asked it last time
was to present faces and hands.
And we found, oh, that region
right there responds like this.
So the key ideas here
is that we can identify
that region in each
subject individually
with a functional scan.
The reason that's important--
which I'll carry on about
in more detail later--
is that the exact location of
that region varies from one
subject to the next.
So if we just grab
the whole fusiform
gyrus or the whole lateral
side of the fusiform
gyrus in each subject,
we'll get lots of stuff
that is that region and
lots of cortical neighbors
that's something else.
And if we took
the exact location
of that region in my
brain and registered it
to any of your
brains and said, OK,
let's take the
part of your brain
that registers spatially as
well as we can with mine,
we're not going to
exactly get the right bit.
So to study that
thing, we've got
to first find it functionally.
And then we can ask
it new questions.
Does that make sense?
OK, if anybody's
unclear about that,
I have actually
online talks that
go through the whole logic
of this in painful detail.
And I'm happy to answer other
questions about it later.
OK, so I put the word
conditions in red
because somebody asked one of
the TAs what a condition was.
And that's not stupid, I
should have made that clear.
This is just experimental design
gobbledygook that means any--
OK, what is the
definition of condition?
In an experimental
design, you have
things that you are
manipulating and measuring.
So in this case, we're
manipulating the stimulus.
And we're measuring the
magnitude of response
in the fusiform face
area or in the brain.
So what we're
manipulating, in this case,
is the stimulus condition.
So that would be one
condition, that's
another condition,
that's another condition.
Does that make sense?
OK, so for your experimental
design assignment for Monday
night, you will be designing
one or more experiments.
And you will be describing
exactly what conditions you are
going to test.
Everybody clear on that?
OK.
All right, so these
data enable us
to rule out those hypotheses.
And now what you could
ask, OK, once you
get more data like this,
have you completely
nailed that hypothesis?
Is there just no way that
hypothesis could be wrong now
given these data and those data?
And I'll let you
percolate on that.
There are ways it
could be wrong,
but you have to work harder
to come up with them.
OK, so skipping ahead,
just to give you the gist.
This field has been
going on for a long time.
And there are now
many, many studies--
100 maybe even, I don't know,
God, maybe even thousands,
I don't know-- studies
of this region in which--
and so this is sort of a summary
statement from a long time ago.
In my lab, we've tested
the response of this region
to lots of different
kinds of stimuli.
With that same
method, localize it
in each subject, measure
its response when people
look at that kind of stimulus,
And so what we know now
was that this region
is found in roughly the
same location in pretty
much every normal subject.
It responds more to faces than
to any other kind of stimuli
anyone has ever tested.
Let me just give you
one example here.
If you haven't seen
this stimulus before,
raise your hand if you
can tell what it is.
Raise your hand if you
can tell what that is.
OK, some of you didn't
quite get it yet.
If you don't see
it, don't worry.
There's nothing wrong with you.
It's a little subtle.
It's a face in profile,
eyes, nose, mouth.
Everyone got it?
OK, so here's the thing.
That's the same stimulus,
it's just upside down.
Another version of the
face inversion effect.
In this case, you can't even
make yourself see the face
when it's upside down.
If you think you see the upside
down version of the face,
you probably have
the wrong bits.
The thing you think is a nose
probably isn't, et cetera.
OK, so this is an extreme
version of the face inversion
effect.
And it's a gift to an
experimental psychologist.
Why is that such a gift?
Because it's the
same damn stimulus.
But in one case you see a face,
in another case you don't.
All we did was tip
it upside down.
And the response of the fusiform
face area is much stronger
to the upright version
when you see the face than
to the inverted
version when you don't.
So that enables us to stifle
a whole line of attack
from all of these hard
core vision people who
early on said,
Kanwisher, your face area
isn't really
selective for faces.
It's selective for these
spatial frequencies or those,
that kind of contrast, or this
kind of shading information.
It's like, no, same stimulus.
It's just upside down.
It makes all the difference.
It's really whether
you see a face or not.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When
you were measuring
the response of
that example, did
you have it so that at first,
when people that the first time
didn't recognize it
and then you told them?
NANCY KANWISHER:
We did that later.
Not in this experiment,
but we did that later.
AUDIENCE: Are they looked see
like what changed [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, so
it's a great question.
And there's a lot you
could do with that.
And actually, I think
other people have published
studies like that since.
I can't quite remember
who all has done it.
But what we did was
most of our subjects,
especially in the context
of a whole experiment,
we chose stimuli so that most
people could see the face
in most of the upright stimuli
and most people could not
see the face in most of
the inverted stimuli.
It wasn't perfect at all.
They didn't see faces in
all of the upright ones
and they didn't fail to see them
in all of the inverted ones.
And that's probably why
this difference in response
is not 2 to 1, but it's close.
But you could do lots of
other experiments like that,
and you should think about
what kinds of designs
would be good ones to
do and what it would
enable you to test exactly.
All right.
So OK, I'm, as usual taking
too long to do things
so I'm just going to throw
out some questions for you
to percolate on and we will
come back to them later
in the course.
Do these data-- the fact that
you can see this so robustly
in all subjects and that
all this evidence suggests
it's really very
selective for faces--
does that tell us that
this region is innate?
It's in the same place, more or
less, in pretty much everyone.
Does that mean it's innate?
Think about it, OK?
It's not immediately obvious.
Another question, does the fact
that this thing responds so
selectively to faces
in pretty much everyone
mean that it's necessary
for face recognition?
What do you guys
think about that?
In the sense of,
does that necessarily
mean that if you
lost that thing,
you wouldn't be able
to recognize faces?
Isabelle.
Is that Isabelle?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Well, I would think to
really test that hypothesis,
you'd have to find
someone that [INAUDIBLE]
in that specific area.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
Exactly, and we'll talk
more about that in a moment.
The critical thing is that it's
fabulous and powerful and cool
to be able to find this
thing in everybody,
measure its response.
It's taken us very far.
But just the fact that
people have that thing
doesn't tell us that you
need it for face recognition.
It just tells you it turns
on when you recognize faces.
This is really important.
We'll keep coming
around to this.
Does this tell us how
face recognition actually
works in the human brain?
No.
I mean, it's important,
but it's barely step zero.
Unfortunately, the
field is kind of still
at step zero for most things.
Step zero's better than
I guess, I don't know,
maybe I should call it step one.
Anyway, it's something, but
doesn't tell us how it works.
OK.
All right, so advantages
and disadvantages
of functional MRI.
Advantages, it
is, as I mentioned
last time, the best
spatial resolution
available for studies
on normal subjects
without opening their heads.
That's what it means
to say noninvasive.
Disadvantages, as
I just said, we
don't know-- just because we see
a response there doesn't mean
that that region is causally
involved in perception
or cognition or experience.
We don't know exactly what
is going on at a neural level
underlying that bold response,
that blood flow change.
It could be any metabolic
change, not necessarily
neuronal spiking.
So it's a little bit--
it's very indirect
and a little imprecise.
Spatial resolution
is much better
than anything else in humans,
but it's appallingly bad
compared to anything that people
who work on animals can do
or they routinely record
from individual neurons
or even dendrites on a neuron.
We are summing over
hundreds of thousands
of neurons in each
pixel or voxel
that we measure
with functional MRI.
It's very expensive.
It's a little cheaper than
that here, but in most places
it's more than $600 an hour.
That is a lot.
There are other-- there are
parts of the brain where
it's really hard
to get any signal
for various physics-y reasons.
And it makes a loud noise,
which is not always a problem,
but it's a problem for some
things like scanning infants
or like doing
auditory experiments.
The temporal resolution is
not even close to the time
scale on which vision happens.
So vision is really fast and
functional MRI is really slow.
Right?
It's slow, why is it slow?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Blood levels
take time to change.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Just takes a long
time for blood flow
to change after the
increase in neural activity.
All right.
OK, so back to our
questions that we're
asking about face perception.
Where do we get
with functional MRI?
Well, actually from both
behavior and functional MRI,
it kind of looks like we
have a distinct system
for recognizing faces than for
recognizing everything else.
I don't think we've
totally nailed it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So quick question
regarding the fMRI.
So the resolution is field
of a couple of seconds?
[INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, some people
would say you could get it
down to a couple hundred
milliseconds but that's debated.
You have to go to great
lengths to do that.
Normal functional MRI, a
couple of seconds at best.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's consider
this next question.
How fast does face
recognition happen?
Now, that may seem like a
completely arbitrary question
to ask, but it's not.
Remember, we're
trying to understand
the computations that
are running in your head
when you recognize faces.
And you might imagine
some computations
that are iterative-- that
involve multiple repeated
testing of hypotheses,
generative models, whatever--
things that involve lots of
iterated feedback versus things
where you just have a
feed forward sweep up
the visual system.
And so there might be
very different time scales
for those different kinds
of mental processes.
So we just went through this.
Functional MRI is not going
to answer this question.
It's just not.
It's a bummer, but that's life.
We're adults, we're
going to just move
on and use a different method.
OK, so there's a bunch
of different methods.
One is kind of been
around forever.
You glue electrodes
on the head, right?
Sometimes you push
the hair apart
or try to find bald people and
glue electrodes right on there.
And you can use, in the old
days, about 10 electrodes,
or you can use in
more modern devices
these nets with a few
hundred electrodes
that you settle onto the head.
And so then you just measure
directly electrical potentials
right on the scalp.
So what's cool about that is
it's totally non-invasive.
And it gives you a beautiful
online temporal measure
of underlying neural activity.
What's not so cool about it is
that electrical potentials blur
all over the scalp and
the spatial resolution
is really awful.
So the analogy has
been made that it
would be like
sticking a microphone
on the inside of the top
of a football stadium
and collecting audio there.
You would know when a
touchdown was scored.
There's a lot of noise all over.
It's like, OK, there's an event,
we detected that event, right?
You might be able to tell a
touchdown from something else.
I don't know about football
so I can't tell you what else.
Anyway, something else, some
other event that could happen.
OK, so that will be useful for
some things, but kind of crude.
But you'd have a hell of a
time telling anything else,
like what one person is
saying to another person
in the bleachers.
So that's the old analogy.
This is changing slightly,
and we'll get to that later.
But first, I want
to briefly mention
one of the assigned
readings that I just
hoped you guys could
figure out on your own.
But just in case you
were confused about it,
the point I wanted you to
get from the Thorpe reading
is he's asking how quickly can
we tell if an image contains
an animal or not?
It's a kind of way to say, how
fast is object recognition?
So what does he do?
He has people look at a bunch
of images and they press this
button if it has an animal
in this button if it doesn't.
Really simple task.
So first question is, why not
just use those reaction times?
We can measure how fast it takes
for people to press a button
after the image comes on.
Why not just use that?
Does that tell us how fast
object recognition occurs?
Yeah, Jimmy.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't because
if you perceive that and then
it also activates
the motor neurons
and it takes time to respond.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, you have
to take all that time to figure
out, OK, I see the animal.
OK, which button is that?
And then which finger do I push?
And then you've got to send
a signal all the way down
here, conduction velocity all
the way down to your finger,
that takes a long time.
And so it includes
all that motor stuff
in with the perceptual stuff.
We could make some guesses
about how long that motor
stuff takes, but it's
still not very precise.
So the point of
the Thorpe paper is
they're basically trying to
collect a reaction time out
of the neurons in
the head, right?
So they're trying to
actually collect--
it's essentially what
they're collecting
in this case is more
of the motor response
because they're collecting
responses over frontal lobes,
right?
And we haven't talked
about this much.
But all of the visual stuff
we've been talking about all
happens in the back of the head.
More motor planning
stuff mostly happens
in the front of the head.
And so they're collecting
responses out of here,
averaging over a bunch
of frontal responses.
And they see the average
response when there's
an animal-- this is
just potential average
over those frontal
electrodes-- is like this.
And when there's no
animal it's like that.
And so what does that tell
us about how fast people can
distinguish whether an
image has an animal or not?
Yes?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's less
than that number.
NANCY KANWISHER: Less than?
AUDIENCE: 150, 160.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
why less than 150?
AUDIENCE: I've read the paper
so it's kind of cheating, so.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's OK.
That's good.
That's fine.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It gives you around--
the 150 second is
giving you a [INAUDIBLE]
saying some process
has been registered
and now you're trying
to do something else
in the case of non-animals.
NANCY KANWISHER: Right.
AUDIENCE: So the
deviation starts
getting you that OK, two
different actions have
started taking place.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So by
that time, the image
ought to have been sort
of fully processed.
So that should be something
less than that number.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah, did everybody get that?
It's actually quite subtle.
So the key thing
is, these curves
diverge right there at 150.
So that tells you that
by 150 milliseconds,
something in your brain is
happening different if there's
an animal and not an animal.
That's the key question.
But what is that something?
It may be your motor
preparation of the response.
In that case, the
actual visual part
happened before,
because you wouldn't
know which button to press
if you hadn't already
recognized it.
So it's an upper bound for
when that process happened,
because maybe it
happened before and we're
looking at a later stage, OK?
Does that make sense?
But also, it's an upper bound
for the beginning of that
process.
Because the fact that those
electrode responses have
diverged doesn't mean
you've finished processing
whether it's an animal or not.
So it's kind of a subtle
business reasoning from this.
OK, so that's all that.
So that's a case with
detecting animals.
What about faces, to get
back to our theme for today?
Yes, you can learn about
the speed of face detection
at least with the ERPs.
And so here's the first paper
that did that back in 1996.
They had electrodes
where are these?
Just right around here and here.
I actually have those electrode
locations tattooed on my scalp,
color-coded anyway.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is ERP just
the same as an EEG, just
in a specific plan e?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, exactly.
It's the same as an
EEG except what you do
is you time lock the data
collection to stimulus onset.
So it actually stands for
Event-Related Potential.
And the reason
it's event-related
is you collect all those
trials and you time
lock to stimulus onset, and
then you signal average.
I had a slide on that
but I took it out.
It was too detailed.
But that's exactly
the idea, yeah.
So here, stimulus onset
is right around here.
This is time going this way.
And what you see--
it's hard to see here,
but the faces are right there.
And at 170 milliseconds
after stimulus onset,
there's a bigger bump
for faces at an electrode
approximately here.
And even more so--
actually, even more so over the
right hemisphere right there.
Compared to cars and scrambled
faces and stuff like that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is ERP
exactly measuring?
Is it just activity?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
So again, it's electrodes
glued on your scalp
or just stuck there with
some kind of icky gel.
And so they're just
measuring potentials.
And so the idea is that's
neural activity somewhere
underneath those electrodes, but
maybe anywhere within inches.
Like a long-- probably average
is over much of the whole lobe
underneath.
So it's very spatially
blurry, but it's
giving you summed idea of
activity under that electrode.
Make sense?
Electrical activity,
because it's
the direct electrical
consequence of neural activity,
it's very precisely time locked,
unlike functional MRI, which
is going by way of blood flow.
OK, so that tells us that we
have a face-specific response
at 170 milliseconds.
And that's sort of more
evidence that there
might be something special in
the brain for face recognition.
That's useful.
It tells us that faces are
discriminated from non-faces,
or they've begun
to be discriminated
from non-faces by
170 milliseconds
after the stimulus comes on.
Make sense?
OK, now do we know
whether the signals coming
from the fusiform face area?
No, we have no idea.
It's probably somewhere
in the back of the head,
because you get it
better with electrodes
back here than
electrodes up here.
But that's about it.
That's all you can tell.
So can we do a little
bit better localizing
the source of that signal?
Well, maybe a hair better
using a very similar method
called magnetoencephalography.
So this is a picture that
Chris Brewer took of Leyla Isik
postdoc in my lab, and
me and the MEG system.
This is in on the other
side of the building.
So MEG is a lot
like EEG and ERPs
except that it detects magnetic
fields, not electric fields.
And it does this by having these
several hundred devices that
are placed right
next to your head
in this big hairdryer thing.
There's 300 devices
in there that measure
teeny tiny magnetic
field changes that
happen with neural activity.
And the crux of the idea
is this is a cross-section
through the brain.
So remember in Graybiel's
dissection, this is cortex here
and this is underlying.
What is this stuff
underneath it?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: White matter.
NANCY KANWISHER:
White matter, yeah.
Well, those are all the fibers.
OK, so the activity that
underlies perception
and cognition mostly
happens in the gray matter
where the cell bodies are.
And so a lot of that
activity goes in a direction
perpendicular to the
cortical orientation
with these cells that cross
the cortical surface like that.
So if you remember 8.02--
if you have activity
that's going
through the cortex like
this, right hand rule,
the magnetic field
here is going to be
a consequence of that electrical
activity in this direction.
It's going to mostly
stay within the cortex.
Everybody see how that's true?
That's not so great, because
our detectors are out there,
outside the cortex.
However, consider the activity
that's in the sulcus in here,
in this fold of the brain.
Electrical activity in this
direction, right hand rule,
will stick outside the brain.
And we can detect it with
our magnetic sensors.
Does that make sense?
So you can sort of see
most cortical activity
better if it's in a
sulcus, or at least in part
of the cortical surface that's
perpendicular to the scalp
where the detectors are just
because of the orientation
in the right hand rule.
OK, so it primarily sees
activity in the folds or sulci,
not in the outer bumps gyri.
Field strengths are
minuscule as a consequence
of neural activity.
So the fields we measure are
10 to the minus 13th Tesla,
a million times weaker than
the Earth's magnetic field.
So you can imagine that if
you set up an MEG system
you need a lot of shielding.
We had a whole rigmarole when
the MEG system was set up
in this building because
it's right near the subway
and the train.
And so there are
many, many layers
of copper shielding
to protect it.
So we can detect these
teeny tiny magnetic fields
from the brain's
activity separated
from the noise of the
outside world, which
is much greater in magnitude.
OK, so-- all right.
So actually, MEG was
invented here at MIT
by this guy, David Cohen.
And this is the first MEG
device ever built, very cool,
way back in 1968.
And what can it tell us
about face perception?
Well, a lot.
I'll give you just one
rudimentary example.
That M170 that you can
detect with scalp electrodes,
you can also detect with
magnetic sensors on the head.
So here's some of our
data from a long time ago.
This is the strength
of the magnetic field
at sites right about out here.
And you can see a
face-selective response also
at 170 milliseconds, just like
you can with scalp electrodes.
So that tells us
that at least you've
started to detect faces
by 170 milliseconds.
That's pretty fast.
And again, it's more
evidence that there's
specialized machinery.
These data don't yet go beyond
the EEG data, the ERP data
from electrical potentials.
But they might, in
principle, and there's
lots of ongoing work
trying to do that.
OK, overview, advantages
of these methods,
both EEG and MEG.
They're non-invasive--
that means you
don't need to open the head.
A very good thing, especially
if you're the subject.
They have very good
temporal resolution.
And if we want to
see computations
unfolding over time in the
brain, this is a good way.
I just said why we'd
I care about that.
OK, so far-- well, never mind,
I'm going to skip this point.
Not that important.
We will get back and do more
sophisticated things with EEG
and MEG in subsequent lectures.
Disadvantages-- spatial
resolution is terrible.
And this is another kind
of ill-posed problem.
So just as the
brain is facing lots
of ill-posed problems in
perception and cognition,
we scientists are facing
ill-posed problems
when we collect electrical or
magnetic activity at the scalp
and try to infer the exact
location in the brain
where it's coming from.
It's a similar problem to the
problem of invariant object
recognition.
There are many
possible configurations
of sources in the brain
that could give rise
to the same set of electrical
and magnetic fields out
of the scalp.
And that means it's ill-posed.
We don't have a way to
get a unique solution.
So all that to say we can't
figure out the exact sources.
We can make some guesses,
but it's not very good.
So what do we do?
Just give up?
No, we use another method.
So here's an amazing method.
This is the one
method in humans that
gives us high resolution
in both space and time.
And that's when we have
the very rare opportunity
to record directly from
inside the human brain.
This happens only in the
context of neurosurgery.
So neurosurgical patients--
like this guy here,
who you'll meet
in a little bit--
this guy had
intractable epilepsy.
And most people
with epilepsy are
treated well by drugs
that suppress seizures.
But some people are just
not responsive to drugs.
And if the seizures
are bad enough,
they can be totally
life disrupting.
If they happen dozens
of times a day,
you just can't
live a normal life.
And under those rather
extreme circumstances,
sometimes the best
option is neurosurgery.
That is, trying to find the
source of those seizures
and trying to remove
it surgically.
OK, so you hope you never have
to go through this or anyone
you care about has
to go through it.
It's no picnic.
But actually, this
surgical treatment
is often very effective.
So when neurosurgeons
decide to do this,
they have to remove a
whole piece of skull bone
to get access to the brain.
They have to go
through what structure
that Ann Graybiel showed you in
her dissection the other day.
What do you have to--
after you take off
the a skull patch?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Dura mater.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Dura mater, exactly.
That nice big piece of
white, leathery stuff
that was sitting over
the surface of the brain.
So you to take off
a piece of skull,
then you need to cut through
and push apart the dura.
And then what they sometimes
do is stick electrodes straight
on the surface of the brain.
And they do that
for two reasons.
One, if they have enough of
them sampled far enough apart,
they can kind of triangulate
and figure out where
is the source of the seizure.
So the patient hangs out
in the hospital for a week
or so with these electrodes
in their head waiting
to have seizures.
And then when they
have a seizure,
the clinicians can
figure out where
the source is so they
know what bit to cut out.
The other reason to do
this is to map functions.
Because once the surgeons decide
they have to go in and cut,
they want to try
to not cut out any
of the most important parts.
I don't know what it
means to have unimportant
parts of the brain, but they
try to avoid language regions
and stuff like that because
then patients really
notice if they lose those
things or motor control regions.
OK, so they map out
functions where they
might be planning their route.
OK, make sense?
Now, some of these patients
are very kind and generous
to the world and say,
yes, you scientists
can measure
responses in my brain
while I look at
your damn stimuli.
And so whenever we can, we ask
them please, please, please,
can we show you some pictures
or play you some tones
or have you read some
sentences while we
record from your brain.
And some of those patients
very kindly let us do that.
And that gives us
the most amazing data
you can get from human brains.
So for example, I had
a rare opportunity
to do this a few years ago
from this lovely guy who
was undergoing
neurosurgery in Japan.
And while he had electrodes in
his brain, a colleague of mine
was there and
emailed me and said,
look where these
electrodes are--
right near regions
I care about--
do you want to show
us some stimuli
and we'll record responses
from those electrodes?
And I said, damn straight I
want to send you some stimuli.
So my students and I stayed
up for a couple of days
and made some stimuli
and shot them to Japan
and got some responses
from those very electrodes.
And here they are.
So this is a strip of two
parallel strips of electrodes
right along the
fusiform gyrus, right
where the fusiform face area
should be in most people.
And here are the responses
of each of those electrodes.
174 is here, what's
173 and so forth.
And what you see is this batch
of electrodes right here--
this is a response when the
patient was looking at faces.
And these are the
responses when they
looked at a whole bunch of
different kinds of stimuli.
Objects, and this
guy is Japanese
so we showed him Kana and
Kanji and digit strings
and other kinds of stuff.
Very low response to
those other things.
This is a extremely
selective response.
It's much more selective than
you see with functional MRI
because we were
recording directly
from the surface of the brain.
Further, we have
time information.
This axis here is
time, and you can
see that that response--
well, you can't see the axis,
but that response
starts up at around 1:30
milliseconds and peaks
up there at around 170.
Everybody clear what
we're seeing here
and why this is so vastly better
than either functional MRI
or MEG or ERPs or anything else?
Make sense?
OK, so these are very,
very precious data.
OK, nonetheless, the
electrodes in this case
are about 2 millimeters
across, each electrode.
And that is about the
size of a functional MRI
pixel or voxel, a
little bit smaller.
It has less blurring because
functional MRI blurs spatially
because it's looking
at blood flow.
So this is a more precise
spatial measurement
than functional
MRI, but it is still
averaging over probably tens
of thousands of neurons,
down from hundreds of thousands
of neurons with functional MRI.
So can we ever get responses
from individual neurons
in the human brain?
Yes, occasionally.
In fact, a paper came out on the
bioRxiv a couple of months ago.
I was on this guy's
PhD thesis defense.
And this is a guy who works with
a neurosurgeon on Long Island.
And this neurosurgeon
specializes
in epilepsy neurosurgery.
And he's very interested in
not damaging people's ability
to recognize faces.
And so he sticks electrodes
to map out neural activity
and to discover seizure foci.
Before the
neurosurgery, he sticks
electrodes in parts of the brain
near the fusiform face area.
So this is a slice like
this through the brain.
I showed you before horizontal
slices, OK, so left and right
are flipped, that region is
right in there, everybody
oriented with this picture here?
So this is an MRI
image of this person.
It was scanned
with functional MRI
before the electrodes
were put in.
And that shows you their
fusiform face area right there.
So now, the neurosurgeons
put in electrodes
for clinical reasons, but the
electrodes this surgeon uses
have these little
tiny micro wires
that come out of the tip
of the electrode that
enable him to record
from individual neurons.
And so these guys,
for the first time,
have recorded from individual
neurons in the fusiform face
area in humans.
And here's an example
of one of these neurons.
So here are the
different stimuli here.
A bunch of different face
stimuli, body stimuli, houses,
patterns, and tools.
And this shows you
time across here.
Each one of those dots is--
this is all the response of
a single neuron that's been
identified in a human brain.
Each dot is an action potential,
is a spike out of that neuron.
So you can see them
happening over time here
to all the faces.
And this is an average
amount of activity
to all of the faces and
average amount of activity
to all the other stimuli.
Make sense?
So that's pretty
breathtaking to me
because I've been using
these very indirect methods
for a long time, inferring
that they must result
from the average across a
lot of neurons doing that,
but it's pretty
awesome to actually see
individual neurons doing that.
Yeah?
OK.
Here's the time course of
responses just averaging
over this raster over
time, showing you
a similar time course to
what I've shown before.
And in this guy's thesis,
he found three other face
selective neurons in the
FFA, but the electrodes
are so rarely in
the right location
that they only have a
few in this whole thesis,
and there they are.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Even if we could
measure individual neurons,
we don't really know
which neuron it is, right?
If I wanted to go back and
find the same neuron Again,
That's pretty much impossible.
NANCY KANWISHER: Forget it.
Yep.
So people like me
who almost never
get to see responses
from individual neurons
in human brains have
kind of neuron envy.
It's like everyone else
in this building has--
they can measure stuff
from dendrites or ion
channels or individual neurons.
They can do all
this amazing stuff.
But actually, there are a lot
of limitations in those methods
too.
And you just put your
finger on one of them.
So they're like, OK they
found those neurons,
there are four neurons.
We can't go back and
find those neurons again.
That's that, right?
And they're probably subtly
different in different brains,
right?
So it's cool and powerful but
has still has many limitations.
OK, does this tell us that
these neurons are involved
in discriminating
one face from another
or just detecting faces?
Can we tell from these data?
Are they just
saying, here's a face
or are they saying, that's Joe?
AUDIENCE: Did they have
different conditions
for different people?
NANCY KANWISHER: These
are different faces here.
What do you think?
What are these neurons doing?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They're just
recognizing faces [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: You
mean just detecting?
No, just say more.
What do you think they're doing?
AUDIENCE: They're just
selecting for faces.
There's no evidence
to show that they
distinguished different faces.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, how about this?
These are different faces here.
AUDIENCE: But one could ask,
if it does involve them sort
of acknowledging
what faces, did they
have to put a name to the face?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Nope, they're just
sitting there looking at stuff.
So bottom line is, we
don't know from this.
It could be just responding
and saying essentially,
there's a face.
But the fact that there's
different responses
to different faces
suggests that maybe there's
some information in there.
If you ran some machine
learning code on this,
you could tell a little bit,
which face was being presented.
Because those neurons are
responding differently
to different faces.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it really
like if they just
showed the same face
repeatedly, wouldn't it just
be like [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
very good question.
Very good question.
That's why I said
suggest, right?
You're absolutely right.
That could be just noise.
It could be that
if you presented
the same face every time you'd
get that same distribution.
You're exactly right.
And so we will talk--
not next time, I think
Wednesday next week.
But anyways, very
soon we'll talk
about methods that enable us to
exactly deal with that question
and ask, is there
actually information
in this pattern of response
across neurons or voxels
or whatever it is?
Or is that just the
noise of variation?
Yeah?
OK.
AUDIENCE: But how many
neurons are in [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER:
Oh good question.
Let's see.
I would say, I
think a few million.
So let's think about it.
Each voxel is about
a half a million,
and they are typically maybe
like 30 voxels, something
like that.
Somewhere on the order of 20
million, something like that.
I mean, with huge error bars.
OK, so this is cool
and tantalizing,
but it doesn't even tell us what
these neurons-- what exactly
they're participating in.
It doesn't tell us if
those neurons are telling
that person which face is there
or maybe what facial expression
the person has or
how old they are
or whether they're male or
female or God knows what else,
right?
And it certainly doesn't
tell us how those neurons
get that information.
Still, it's cool.
OK, so intracranial
recording, both with the grids
that I showed you and
the single unit version.
Advantages are, this
is the only method
in humans that has both
pretty good spatial resolution
and temporal resolution
at the same time.
Disadvantage-- well, you need
to have a craniotomy, which
is no picnic, to put it mildly.
You need to have a huge
piece of your skull removed
and neurosurgery.
And that means
that the only times
we get to do this are when
it's required clinically
and everything is under
control of the doctors,
as it should be.
So the doctors make
all the choices
about where the
electrodes go, and we just
get to sit in the background
and say, please, please,
please, look at these
stimuli, but try not to hassle
the patients too much.
Right now there's a
patient in Albany,
New York who has
electrodes right
over a really exciting
part of the brain
to us that I'll talk
about in a few months.
This patient has electrodes that
respond specifically to music.
We will talk about that later.
It's pretty amazing.
And for the last couple
of days, Dana and I
have been-- mostly Dana
has been collecting stimuli
because we really
want to ask questions
about the response
of those electrodes.
And this patient
is not too thrilled
listening to our stimuli.
So we finally said, oh,
OK, tell the patient
they can just do
Instagram on their phone
and we'll play the
stimuli in the background.
So hopefully, we'll have
cool data from that soon.
OK, so to say that these data
are limited and hard to control
is an understatement.
We basically can't
control it at all.
All we can control
occasionally is the stimuli.
And it also, like
functional MRI,
just because we see those
beautiful responses,
it doesn't tell us
how those responses
are connected to behavior.
So that's a real challenge.
So that won't do.
We need to get
beyond this problem.
I keep saying this
method is great,
but it doesn't tell
us the causal role
of that neural phenomenon
in cognition and behavior.
As scientists, science
is all about discovering
causal mechanisms.
We're not just interested in
what is correlated with what,
we want to know
what's causing what.
That's really of the
essence, and so we
need to do better here.
So what are we going to do?
Somebody mentioned a
while ago, maybe it
was Isabelle, that
one of the ways
to do that and ask whether the
face area is causally involved
in face perception
is to look at a case
where the face area is altered.
So there's a bunch
of ways to do that.
And one of them--
OK, that's just a review.
We said faces are
recognized fast
but we haven't
learned much more.
How do we test causality?
OK, patients with
focal brain damage.
Here is a patient.
These are vertical
slices through the back
of this patient's head.
OK, let me get oriented.
The slice is maybe this here.
And as you go rightward,
you're marching back
in the brain like that.
Everybody oriented?
What's this thing right there?
AUDIENCE: Cerebellum.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
cerebellum, right.
That thing right there
is this patient's lesion
that spans several slices
going back like that.
And this patient's lesion
looks a whole lot like my FFA.
There's my FFA, greater
response to faces than objects,
on similar slices.
We don't have functional
MRI from this patient
so we don't know exactly
where this guy's FFA was.
But there's a good bet that
it was blitzed by that lesion,
because it's right in the
zone where it usually lands.
And this patient can't
recognize faces at all.
And importantly, the
patient is absolutely
normal at recognizing objects.
No problem whatsoever
at recognizing objects.
How does this take us
beyond functional MRI?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It implies causation.
NANCY KANWISHER: Speak up.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, say more.
What does it tell us?
AUDIENCE: So because of the
fact that area's damaged
and then it makes it to not
be able to recognize faces
and I can see that
there's causality that oh,
that area's [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
It says you need that
bit to recognize faces.
But also says something else.
What else does it?
AUDIENCE: That you don't need
it for recognizing objects.
NANCY KANWISHER: You don't need
So this is actually
really strong evidence
that that bit of brain is
very specialized for face
recognition.
Specialized and necessary
for face recognition.
OK, so--
AUDIENCE: Can that person
still detect faces?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, yes.
Good question, absolutely.
OK, so let me just distinguish--
this person here has
prosopagnosia-- that means
a selective deficit in face
recognition--
like Jacob Hodes, who
I described yesterday,
who has no brain
damage whatsoever
but has just never been able
to recognize faces at any point
in his life.
So this syndrome can arise just
from some weird developmental
thing where you're atypical and
you're just really bad at it,
or it can result from damage
to that part of the brain.
So now we're talking
about the case of damage,
but in both cases,
people with prosopagnosia
have no problem knowing
that a face is a face.
They just don't know who it is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Has there
ever been a case
of problems of people who
can't recognize faces who
[INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Indeed.
Indeed.
Jacob Hodes, who I talked
about last time who is just
absolutely awful at
face recognition,
including family
members, close friends,
can't do it, like not at all.
He has a very normal
looking fusiform face area.
So after I told you that I
had that conversation with him
a dozen years ago or something
like that, I scanned him.
And he had a beautiful fusiform
face area, like textbook.
It looked-- well, looked like
mine, which is a damn fine one
if I do say so myself.
And I looked at that
and I went, oh shit.
I better publish this
before someone else does.
And I didn't get
my act together,
and then a whole bunch of
papers came out saying,
oh, people with
developmental prosopagnosia
have normal looking face areas.
Take that, Kanwisher.
What do you say about that?
And it was a little shocking.
But upon further reflection,
it's not really devastating,
right?
I mean, it's bracing,
it's informative.
But it tells you that
having a face area that
is a region that responds
more to faces and objects
isn't sufficient for normal
face recognition, right?
You need other stuff.
What might that other stuff be?
Well, the circuits in
there need to work right.
It's not enough to just respond
more to faces and objects.
To recognize faces, they need
to be able to distinguish faces
from objects.
We don't know if
that's working right.
What else do you need?
AUDIENCE: Memory.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Memory, absolutely.
Yes, you need to remember faces.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Could
be, but in Jacob's case,
it was close friends
he couldn't recognize.
So what's another
possible account
of how could he have a
normal face area and yeah?
David?
AUDIENCE: It might be a gap
between recognizing a face
and connecting that to
recognizing a person.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah.
Or to put that
neuroanatomically,
you got to get the
information out of there.
maybe, for all we know,
that little face area
is working perfectly.
Maybe that face area knows who
that person is, in a sense.
But if the connection's
out of that brain
region to the rest of
the brain are messed up,
it doesn't do you any good.
You need to be able to read
that information out and act
on the basis of it.
Anyway, that's a big sidebar.
Point is, you can
have prosopagnosia
either as just a
developmental disorder
or as a result of brain damage.
Oh, God, I knew this
was going to happen.
All right, so OK, so very
briefly, it messes up ability
to discriminate and recognize
faces, not your ability
to detect a face, right?
So as [INAUDIBLE]
had asked, it's
not just you can't tell
the thing is a face,
they're fine with that.
Importantly, they are normal
and voice recognition.
So it's not that
they're confused
about distinguishing
one person from another.
They can do it fine from
audition, just not from vision.
In the rare cases where
the lesion is small,
it can be very specific, leaving
object recognition intact.
More often, there's
kind of a blurry mess.
You have a big lesion and a
bunch of things are affected.
OK, so we've talked about that.
OK now, it's very important
in neuropsychology reasoning--
like we want to say, OK,
that's really powerful,
the case of prosopagnosia.
You lose that bit, you
can't recognize faces.
And that establishes
a kind of causality
that we didn't have before
with just functional MRI.
But is that sufficient to say
that that region is specialized
for face recognition only?
It's not.
Whenever I ask this,
the answer's no.
Your task is to say, why?
How could you have great
difficulty at recognizing faces
and be OK at object recognition?
And yet, not have a deficit
that's specific to faces?
How might that arise?
You guys have suggested this
hypothesis in different context
before.
Yes?
You look like you know.
No?
AUDIENCE: But I just you
could do other things.
It doesn't have to only
be for facial recognition.
Because it response to
animals [INAUDIBLE],, right?
NANCY KANWISHER: Sort of.
But the question here is--
OK, let's just start bare bones.
You have a lesion, you get
around fine in the world,
you can do everything else
but you have a real problem
recognizing faces.
Does that mean that the
region lesioned is specialized
for face recognition per se?
AUDIENCE: There might
be other [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: That's true.
There could be other things
going on, absolutely.
But let's suppose they're not.
Let's suppose you had good
reason to think there weren't.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It could be--
it'd be a path--
it could be one
point in a pathway.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's true.
It could be totally
a point in a pathway.
Absolutely, that's
another account.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Well, I couldn't
get last comment, so.
NANCY KANWISHER: He said
maybe you damage a pathway.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe there's
some other function
we haven't tested
in that person.
NANCY KANWISHER: All
these are very good
alternative hypotheses.
You guys are very good at this.
The one I'm fishing
for is, maybe
face recognition is just
harder than object recognition.
Maybe the part that's damaged
is just generically involved
in object recognition,
but you damage
part of the object recognition
system and face recognition
takes a bigger hit
because it's harder.
Right?
Does that make sense?
Do you see how the
case of prosopagnosia
is consistent with that?
So that means we cannot infer
from these data alone that that
region's specialized
for face recognition.
Now, we can do various
things like test
them on really hard versions
of object recognition.
And people have done that.
But there's another kind of data
that are really powerful here.
And that's when we have
the opposite syndrome.
So there's only a
couple of cases of this.
The best one is called CK,
published in a paper in 1997.
You don't need to remember that.
The point about this
is that this guy
has the opposite syndrome.
He's severely impaired
at object recognition.
He can't tell a
chair from a table
from a car from a
toaster, but he's
100% normal at face recognition.
Totally normal at
face recognition.
In fact, better than average.
Do you see how
that's in some ways
even more powerful evidence
that face recognition goes
on in specialized
brain machinery
than the case of prosopagnosia?
Face recognition isn't
even a special thing
that sits on top of
normal object recognition.
It's a totally
different pathway.
You can have no ability
to recognize objects
and your OK a face recognition.
Does everybody see how
that's really powerful?
And how those two
kinds of evidence
together are vastly more
powerful than either one alone.
Well, that's called
a double association.
We'll skip all of that for now.
Doubled associations are
particularly powerful
examples--
powerful forms of
evidence in cognitive
neuroscience where we have
opposite syndromes that
collectively make it really
hard to wiggle out and come up
with alternative
accounts other than
that there's a bit of brain
that's really specialized
for face recognition.
It's not just that face
recognition is harder,
or else you'd never
get this syndrome.
All right, I just wanted
to finish that point.
OK now, how much time do
I have until the quiz?
15 minutes, OK good.
AUDIENCE: 13.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, good.
We're going to skip over TMS.
I'm sorry about that, guys.
Someday I'll learn to
time things in a lecture.
Actually, I knew this was
going to happen, I just--
we'll get back to TMS later.
And we will skip to
the most amazing method
in all of cognitive
neuroscience for which-- we're
going to come back to this
dude who you met before who
has the face selective responses
in that part of his brain.
Remember how I said that
even though these data are
gorgeous and spectacular
and the only way
we can get high spatial and
temporal resolution together,
but they don't
tell us causality?
Right?
That's true here?
Resolution doesn't
get you causality.
To test the causal
role of something,
you need to mess with it.
So it turns out that sometimes
the neurosurgeons electrically
stimulate through
those same electrodes.
And they do that to test the
function of those regions
causally.
They also do it to test their
hypotheses about the location
of the seizure foci.
So in those rare
cases, where you
have a patient like this
with selective electrodes
like that where the clinicians
decide that they are going
to electrically
stimulate through some
of those electrodes,
then we're in a position
to kind of have it all
scientifically, right?
I don't mean to be so crude.
This is a horrible situation
for that lovely guy to be in,
but scientifically,
it's extremely powerful.
So I'm going to show you--
we did in fact have
an opportunity.
The same guys in
Japan emailed me
and said, OK, we're going to
be stimulating that electrode.
What do we do?
And I said, OK, have
him look at faces
and have them look
at other objects
and ask him if anything changes.
And I'm going to show
you a video of what
happens when that goes on.
OK, here we go.
Oh, and I need to
turn on the audio.
OK, he's getting stimulated
right there and he says--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NANCY KANWISHER: He's such
a good subject, this guy.
- One more time.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- His eyes.
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, that tells us
that that region is causally
involved in face perception.
Is it causally
involved in perception
of things that aren't faces?
He's getting stimulated
in the same electrode.
He doesn't know that
there's a face area.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NANCY KANWISHER: He
doesn't know which
electrode is being stimulated.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NANCY KANWISHER: This is a
Kanji character on a card here.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- One more time.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: Awesome, huh?
What did we just learn?
AUDIENCE: You can trigger it.
NANCY KANWISHER: You
can trigger it, yeah.
Yeah.
So what does that tell us about
the function of that region?
Why is this-- I mean, it's
amazing to see, no question,
but what does it tell
us scientifically?
AUDIENCE: It's specific.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
How does it tell us
that it's specific?
AUDIENCE: Because
when you stimulate it,
it particularly sees a face.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
And what happens
when he's looking
at things that aren't faces?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
So if that region
was causally involved
in perception of things
that aren't faces,
you might think that
it would distort--
the box would look different or
the ball would look different
or the Kanji would
look different.
It doesn't, there's
just a face on top.
So I think that's
very strong evidence
that that region is not
only causally involved
in face perception, but very
specifically causally involved
in face perception only.
Everybody get that?
Do I have to stop?
OK.
OK, I have another video.
Consider-- and we'll
get back to this later--
consider other alternative
hypotheses to this.
This is pretty powerful.
This is more powerful than
most of the other things
I showed you, but
there's always ways
to come up with
alternative hypotheses,
and that's the
business we're in here.
So be percolating on
what other control
conditions you'd
want from this guy
to really believe these data.